[Music]
growing up this was the soundtrack to
one of my favorite games resin evil but
out of context well it was sort of a
massive joke on the internet and I had
the same reaction probably a lot of
people had where was like I can't is
this actually in the game is this real
in this case the emotional reaction is
just like what is this real is this a
hoax oh but it was real and just as
unbelievable as the song is the story
behind its composer mom aru samuragochi
the deaf composer who was acclaimed as
Japan's Beethoven for the digital age
however he wasn't deaf at all and
someone else was writing his music he's
the video game composer that fooled the
world almost now before we get into the
scandal I wanted to get a broader
perspective on what some of my GameSpot
friends thought of this song before they
knew the truth behind it what's up mate
stop are you doing I need you to listen
to the song right now
[Music]
there's something about this song I
really like it reminds me of crawling
out of bed not looking forward to the
day a cacophony of what is supposed to
be a military song from a SNES game
jumbo is that what's happening it's like
a kids pressing all the buttons at once
it's like when you cat walks along a
keyboard it sounds like a cat walking on
a keyboard so how would you feel if I
told you that was composed by a deaf guy
I wouldn't I shouldn't laugh at though
that's awful but yeah that makes sense
curve ball he wasn't actually deaf he
faked it what wait but the guy who did
write it could he hear but during the
2014 Sochi Olympics acclaimed Japanese
figure skater Daisuke Takashi was
supposed to perform to sonatina for
violin a piece by Samara goichi and then
a press conference interrupted Japanese
daytime television featuring this man he
claimed that mama is Samara goichi the
composer of video game soundtracks and
the Hiroshima symphony did not write any
of his own music
he was takashi miike key a composer
arranger and professor at the tokyo
college the man behind all of Samara
goat-cheese music oh and Samberg oh geez
deafness that was all fake he could hear
just fine Takashi had been ghost
composing for Mom Maru for 18 years and
it started with the Resident Evil
director's cut DualShock version
soundtrack which was different from the
original 1996 soundtrack so why the
different soundtrack well Capcom was re
releasing Resident Evil 1 in 1998 for
the cusp of its sequels release and to
give the two year old game some sort of
facelift they commissioned the
up-and-coming deaf composer Mamoru
samara goichi to give the game an
orchestral soundtrack which differed
from its 1996 release
so that faked hearing loss was all part
of a publicity stunt that served him
success for many many years being quoted
by time Asia for things like the saddest
thing for me is not to be able to hear
an orchestra perform my work but as big
as claim to fame was his Symphony number
one Hiroshima which kind of became a
cathartic anthem in response to the 1945
bombing and it was that that propelled
him into stardom
Japan's Beethoven for the digital age
until the 2014 Sochi Olympics now
there's a lot to unpack with this
revelation but if there's one glaring
thing I could not stop thinking about is
that this sonically insulting piece of
music was composed by someone who
actually knew what he was doing and that
made me wonder is there something we're
missing what if the mansion basement
song actually isn't that bad I said the
classical guitar you know I was really
fascinated by music theory especially in
some of the later courses where you
start talking about kind of serialism
and poly tonality poly tonality just
means it's a song with two keys going on
at the same time which sounds horrendous
i I never liked it like it sounds like
two very clashing ideas at the same time
which is it it is a mood you know that
is a context if that's what you're going
for there you go I just started kind of
seeing patterns and stuff in music that
I didn't see patterns before I i sat
down with it and I transcribed it note
for note I had one day where I was like
all I'm gonna do today is try to figure
out what's going on in this song and I
sat there and every second just said
like okay what notes am i hearing here
so then once I was done with that I
decided okay now if I make a chord line
to this how can I make these notes make
sense like almost sound that like they
were intentional
[Music]
I know deeply all the contours and
everything it's interesting because
there there is a very distinct
call-and-response going on where you
have this musical idea and then it's
repeated you know you have this bed and
then you have it happen again very
shortly afterwards there's there's some
kind of planning here
[Music]
it's interesting because there is a
specific compositional technique that's
being used that has been used actually
by a lot of contemporary classical
musicians to evoke true feelings of
dread and that is whenever you take the
interval of a half-step just two notes
very very close together and you start
stacking that on top of one another so
you have a bunch of different musicians
and you didn't like in this case
synthesizer is playing very very close
together and sometimes that actually can
be done to a very very good effect like
a very dread inducing effect there's a
piece by the Hungarian composer Georgi
Ligeti
named lux aeterna
it's from the soundtrack of 2001 a Space
Odyssey and it actually uses the exact
same technique where you have these
half-step intervals very close together
I mean immediately it is beautiful and
eerie
yeah it's bizarre it's like there's two
songs happening at the same time one of
which conveys on ease when the other one
is kind of peaceful
I would actually listen to this in my
free time I think there is like there is
this underlying structure to it that is
coming from a fairly serious place it
just it wasn't a real heist that way at
all it's a very goofy sounding piece of
music but there are plenty of other
goofy sounding pieces of music and we
don't react to them maybe in the same
way music is very context dependent
music can be used for many different
things be used to score videogames to be
used to score film we can listen to it
and dance to it you have to understand
what the intent of a piece of music is
so sometimes you have very strange
aggressive pieces of music which in
certain contexts would be weird but in
other contexts would be perfect and in
this case you know I can't really think
of the best context for this it clearly
was supposed to create a sense of dread
and it failed miserably there is a lot
of subjectivity and art but there is
also a degree of objectivity what is the
art trying to do and in this case it's a
bad piece of art because it didn't do
what it was trying to do in my opinion
anyway now the thing that I find so
fascinating about the song is that it
seems to have taken on a life all its
own completely separate from the scandal
itself inspiring people like Jules to do
a metal rendition and who only vaguely
knew about the composer behind it and
furthermore that the song kind of became
a joke with its own identity thus
spawning a ton of memes there's always a
lot of means the scandal part of it
wasn't as big a discussion topic as the
song itself the internet likes to burn
fuel in its memes and that kind of stuff
so people took it it was the talk for a
bit and then disposed of it it's been
more interesting as a meme once people
forgot about it almost because when it
first came out we didn't have things
like mean templates meme formats the for
picture format wherever it may be we
were just putting things out and going
ha ha this is weird retweet or like or
whatever it may be say something about
it I think all this is to say is that
this song's legacy isn't in the wild
story of its composer but rather us the
community the people who heard this and
shared it in disbelief so what happened
to Takashi and Mamoru in the end well
after the scandal Takashi was given full
recognition for all of his work and was
even commissioned to do a follow-up to
his first symphony hiroshi AMA entitled
Symphony number 2 litany as for a
samurai goichi well it's safe to say
that he faded into obscurity
unlike the song people think he made now
it's worth noting that the entirety of
the resonable 1 director's cut DualShock
version isn't all that bad it's just
well it's certainly memorable whether or
not this for the right reasons
I don't know so while it's easy to hear
that soundtrack and assume that the
person who made it had no idea what they
were doing know that they did and that
they're actually a talented composer and
that there is theory and intent behind
specifically the mansion basement it's
not nonsense it just may not be your jam
or most of our jams for that matter and
unfortunately we will never discover why
this happened or who approved it those
are pieces of puzzle that are locked
behind a door we may never find a key to
what I can say is that this song is
probably the perfect rendition to this
whole story fragmented confusingly
layered and well weirdly compelling
[Music]
now this is still awful hey thanks for
watching this episode of remember when
the working at home with my cats Edition
if you dug this you should check out
some of our other ongoing shows like
loadout and audio logs there's also true
fiction which I also host on GameSpot
universe please like comment and
subscribe if you're not already it would
mean a lot to me personally ok bye